Oh welcome to this video putting the
Rainmaker again i am just played him
down three games before and I had this
great position out of the opening which
I then screwed up and but then still one
let's see how he improves on the opening
last time he really was just a pawn down
okay like this do I go is six here or
taking 1c3 mmmm taking on c3 looks kind
of kind of sluggish mad this I don't
know I'm really making this this up here
I know that this is not so bad for black
but we don't know any details
yeah I need some foothold in the center
if we go see for again and I take a
knight c6 we have the same idea as in
the game earlier no he doesn't do that
okay night sorry Bishop takes there
might even be Bishop takes h7 and so
I'll take with the pawn yeah this is
interesting now I can take one if three
nights is six this is very comparable on
a comparable it's kind of similar to
what we had earlier like giving up the
bishop but having some play against you
five there's also the d4 square that
sometimes can be really nice for the
night
yeah Queen g3 or Bishop f4 those most
look very normal Queenie for also might
be a move just threatening mate no I
have to go with you six basically
yeah it looks dangerous but sometimes if
you haven't it if you want to attack i'm
a weekend kingside you need nights
subtypes to to break through where I
don't see how he text me in a dangerous
right here without night ya hear of
queen bee eight double attacking a 5 +
b2 it's a bit cheeky a bit cheeky to
trying to grab a pawn but I still do it
I'm grabbing him or not am I blundering
everything here and don't see it
and I have Queen g4 as a maybe decent
decent square
yep I think I go there
hmm very quickly played I go d8 just
cover d7 wow he's really playing very
quickly him so I cheek we should take
them that's pretty pretty strong yeah
but can I go I mean where am I going
with the Queen there's some other square
Quincy's three maybe
Quincy three and one cannot calculate
this rock d7 hope 27 up 27 as his
background looks very weak and work the
aid maybe
hmm isn't there some trickery going on
your thing stinks to have a better look
than look the ATM probably not probably
not
it's also pretty good for white I guess
takes Bishop takes and he does if he
does something against this week back
rank I'm in trouble J Quincy six is made
only one but if he oh well I'm always
attacking c2 and maybe I can just play
the bishop now one that you for actually
94 Queenie eight
I have check on e 1 and Bishop 90 to go
actually it's kind of interesting I
cannot calculate this this this this is
fawn yeah let's get about that time our
hero is really not reacting in any way
Bishop cheeks sorry bishop moves can
also check here threatening 92 it's
pretty annoying and the bishop hangs
okay this chemist is for the moment we
just step step out of the Queen aid with
a chimp own Queen you three maybe check
your words it's probably not not good
age six
yeah I think it just drops on age 60 I
could have taken you three actually
would have been maybe even easier check
check check check check mate tough game
tough game yeah I already decided to
mean let's check around here maybe
father and starts you for no heat again
and this I don't have to take
necessarily button it is interesting
she's six well I don't know queen bee
eight I mean he just didn't he could
have found played something like like
this for example trying to just cover
this a little bit but I guess he didn't
see it couldn't be eight at all I mean
not that I'm sure that is good but it
wasn't really so necessary for why to
give up on and let's say like up the
ante like that yeah the engine is
fearless wants to grab hmm but that that
held a little bit like a little bit too
much this and this engine says 0 0 0
which is very believable shine and thank
you for and queen a8 is a draw ok yeah
my idea was and I'm not really sure if
it works I wanted to do this actually
and now I thought maybe 92 but it's the
same with check so this is complete
bogus
shaggy this of course and take him check
check yeah that's set to draw really I
mean yeah that is also drawn yeah this
is this is losing really I guess yeah
yeah after that it's definitely losing
yeah here it was a bit simpler to just
take this home and then BB the peas up
for us for nothing that's it's a bit
simpler okay well thanks for watching